what's going on reject nation i'm greg
look who's with me today
it's ken alvarado the miracle of cat
alvarado is here
do you know who zach king is no zach
king you know i'm not even gonna say
anything about him
he is uh but i'm going to apparently he
is
a he does magic that's all i say became
popular on the internet with these magic
videos
there's a compilation release from him
you'll like it there's like editing
involved
it's not like oh my god that's
clearly fake it it's it's still very
impressive
i'm saying too much guy calvara has a
podcast called villains of history tell
them about a cat
okay we talk about horrible people from
history with comedians as guests we're
very funny and we make
sad history funny so listen to it yeah
apple podcast spotify or stitcher and we
also do it about recent events
oh we do like the most horrible tragic
recent events could be yesterday and we
just make them
funny we do that
i thought it was history though well
yesterday it's history
that's true there you go whatever
terrible awful
news just let us know we'll make it
funny
and not insensitive not at all i'm
trying yes and
okay let's move on that part was clearly
sarcasm i hope that became clear
[Music]
this is summer magic oh it's a
it's a palm tree oh come on
[Music]
it's like a sandwich
that cool wait there was no sandwich
there before and then there was a
crunch i don't like to push my friends
in the pool
i like to throw them you ready josh
it's summertime baby oh come on that's
cool
that was pretty cool you wanna help me
clean my yard turn your phone upside
down in three
two one
oh that's awesome
thanks deborah anne waterman
come get your watermelon here
wow how does he do this it's so
impressive
morning zach hey todd
whoa wow
ah there's so so it's such wonderful i'm
gonna tell you the trick
perfect car wash using just a little bit
of water
all right so i'm going to run over here
and set you down
okay right there
[Music]
now your car is as good as new oh no
center knee naked
[Music]
oh no he turned into balls
oh my god is there going to be a real
fire come on you're liam he's going to
set the kids on fire
you want to roast some more yeah jason
let's do a fire come on
here we go
ah brain freeze
cool it's the bottle cap challenge
that's real magic can i get a photo
cheese all right thank you
it's kind of cool
oh hey buddy
he's so good at that
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh explain a little catch with myself
whoa just playing a little catch with
myself
he's so good at editing i know he's
amazing
wow how do you do this
that's amazing
[Music]
it works
oh no heavens
what oh come on all right
time for the 0.9 iron oh how cool
no what did you see that
he's so good one more hour
wow just don't know what he's gonna do
so crazy does anyone else feel like
these don't really work
wait hey what are you doing it's a red
light dude
[Music]
hey look before you cross the street
[Music]
i love it oh that's it i'm so into that
that's fun i know right isn't that
impressive
it is you said it would be a fun thing
and it was a fun thing
this is a fun thing you're a poet and
you didn't even know it
i don't know how to pull that up
i know i delivered with showing you a
video that would
totally satisfy that
need and desire totally i have no idea
how he does this i first discovered him
um he was on a beloved talk show host
show can you guess who
i'm referencing by my sarcastic tone
ellen
allen degeneres i was like who is this
guy i haven't seen any of these that
he's compiled here but i've seen a whole
bunch
in the past and every single time it
still never fails
to amaze me with this sense of wonder
and joy
absolutely it's like a comedian trick
you know i've heard like comedians and
magicians
they're not too far apart and they're
their greatest enemy
yeah you don't agree with that you don't
think there's anything i don't think
there's a war between comedians and
magicians and i also think magicians are
way cooler
i mean but i would date
neither in case you're one really i
think they'd both be terrible
what about this kind of magician who's
not real magic but you know clearly
there's something impressive about this
kind of magic where
the idea is not to make you think it's
real whereas most magicians you watch
them and you're in the crowd like uh
so you move the card here or some [ __ ]
like that with him
it's obviously editing tricks that he's
doing but it's all it's like
one take so there's something still
incredibly impressive about how he
captures it
i mean it's a lot like magicians in the
sense that we also know magicians
aren't really doing magic they're have
they're doing optical illusions and
that's what's going on here
but editing you don't know for sure it's
definitely optical illusions and magic
i mean here yeah but if you're gonna say
magicians aren't doing real magic let's
come
come on it's all that's like saying
comedians don't do real comedy you know
my fingers are gone now they're back
that's all it takes
see in one shot clearly no editing
is that impressive guys i just hid my
fingers
and then now they're back but that's
what i mean like a lot of magic that
magicians did watch pen and tongue yeah
this is what she means
watch pen and tell her they'll show you
but this is great like it's just
skilled i love anything that shows a lot
of skill and that's what like
this stuff takes time it clearly because
you have to think
he has to go through all the steps of
thinking and planning and it's a lot of
effort
so i admire it i respect it well zack
king would be happy
he's like all i care about is earning
cat alvarado's respect and i got it
today
you got it zach and my skill is pulling
up a video
that is worthy enough of your time
and we just did it all right guys well
zach king go check out more of his
content because he is absolutely
incredible as you can tell subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell
uh check out cat alvarado's podcast
villains of history
also cat you have a uh a fundraiser i do
you're running for president or
something right i mean it's for someone
else who's running for president
it's a 12-hour comedy zoom-a-thon we've
broken it down into 12
different shows just back to back to
back to back and you can watch it for 12
if you go to the link below in the
description box
and it's to raise money for the biden
campaign
do it i'm voting for joe rogan this year
sorry it's been nice
oh a patron of the day shout out if
you're still here
adelia chamberlain kat and i reacted to
this video that involved magic and i
thought
who deserves to have the most magical
year
me man i want to talk about me and you
know
you adelia now you went through some
pretty crazy stuff over labor day
weekend i'm sorry to hear about what
happened at the beginning of september
for you here's hoping by the end of this
year you and i both get what we want you
know what the hell i'm talking about
and uh i hope that 2021 could be a
magical year for
you especially i know that you have been
getting involved in the shmo down a lot
more
helping out behind the scenes helping
build the community
keep showing your support and love
towards us and i just wanted to say that
there's anyone who i could have a
magical wish for i'm hoping it's you
because you rock my socks off you rock
john's butt hole off
oh it's awesome
around right now you can't see it
disgusting it's all out of luck
beautiful because you're providing that
you are inspiring that within me
and i also hope that when dune comes
around since i know you're a big dune
fan
that you are mediocrely satisfied with
the movie because let's face it nothing
can be better than the book am i right
oh yeah there are a lot of people who
will agree with you
you see this
that's me dusting off 2020 [ __ ]
it's all going away feel it blue blowing
the building blowing the crap away
feel it welcoming a cleaner 2021 for you
you're letting it go you're bringing
better things in
manifest
too loud joe oh sorry i i was leaving
[Music]
you